but there's going to be a funny movie
coming out you're also directing yeah
have you directed before feature I have
directed a feature yeah what's it called
it's called fudgy wedgie fudge face
and it's a movie I
it's a war film no it's a it's an alien
movie it's about it's about an alien
that crashes on Earth is it real is this
yeah fudgy wedgie Fudge Face
maybe is there a trailer from it yeah
there's a trailer can we play the
trailer and
there it is here it is this is the
trailer we'll just watch it for a second
okay turn up the volume
Studios yeah
they said that one day they would come
they said that contact would be made
foreign
of intelligence but did anyone tell them
that on planet Earth Some Humans not
know stuff
a potato peeler his name Elmore P fudge
his occupation clog maker
his IQ somewhere between a carpenter ant
and sometimes they screw up your order
at Denny's too I don't know why it just
happened and an onion bun
what is the first human they ever met
was a greased up raisin bread eating
celery child
what if it was up to him to save them
from the human race are we sure about
this yes sir
we got another Landing
I don't do that kind of work anymore
what if it was him who became
their friend hello
[Music]
ah
no more P fudge she brings a couple of
hotties like you to a place like this
the dumbest man in the world
and I come to further drinks
the smartest being in the universe
destiny
Elmore where did you say your friend was
from and not even a guy who thinks
clouds are puffy floating old lady wigs
could push them apart
because everyone needs a gravy-stained
country fried
[Music]
face
sandwich in my face
say goodnight Sawtooth
[Music]
next event
if you want sweet Slytherin Boston
cheesecake
[Music]
prefer to continue to hold
that was amazing
when did you do that
about
12 years ago and it took me six years to
make that movie
wait so you only finished it six years
ago no I finished it like 12 years ago
18 years ago you started yeah
Bobby Lee's in it and uh Andy Dick and
Michael Rosenbaum Tom Papa yeah
and did it get released on no I entered
it in some film festivals and it
actually won for like funniest and best
sci-fi and things like that please and
uh it took me six years because I just
did it on the weekends I did everything
myself the biggest crew I ever had was
probably three people
and did you sell it to you can can
people see it on a streamer or just on
YouTube where they can uh I think it's
on Amazon maybe but you could actually
buy the DVD until recently but it's uh
it it sold out so now I'm I'm trying to
get it so you can watch it digitally on
on the Internet or whatever it is well
why don't you sell it to the like
Netflix or something because it's too
stupid no no it's the stupidest movie
ever made it's so dumb
it's really stupid the one you're making
now though is a legitimate like yeah the
one I'm doing now is like a like
commercial sort of like uh fairly
Brothers type movie right but this is
funny too oh yeah it's I I loved making
that I mean I I had I had some of the
scenes I literally strapped my
girlfriend to the front of that red
truck
and she was like holding the camera
while we were driving
stuff I had to do to make that movie is
that you're not with her anymore are you
no no she didn't like the stretch marks
and that's on me that's on me too many
yoga classes and
can I ask you what the budget of that
movie was that the the biggest expense
was I I bought the red truck for the
movie it was six grand
and then I rented a location out in the
desert like a diner yeah and a gas
station that was about four or five
grand and then everything else I just
kind of did on my own so I bet it was
about 13 14 Grand not 3 000. once you
had the desert and once you had the
truck yeah because I shot everything in
the desert for free I would just I went
out to the Salton Sea do you know the
Salton Sea behind Palm Springs yeah I
shot out there I shut out in Death
Valley I just drove all over and just
took the shots out in nature you know
and I just asked all my great friends to
do cameos in it and
yeah
why did we didn't know each other at
that point I knew him I've known him for
like 18 years but we weren't hanging out
is what I'm saying I used to hang out
with him all the time he values Andy
Dick more than he I would have had you
in it not midnight minute
hopefully I've been this new one I hope
I can make time to do it but this one is
really funny I read the script and I and
I look forward to it and I bet you'll
see it in theaters and on streamers but
I think that this is holding up the test
that holds to the test of time that you
should go does your agent know that you
have this movie not really it's like
kind of a labor of love I want here's
what happened I you come to Hollywood
and you always do other people's
material you do other people's scripts
you do other people's whatever
and I thought before I die I want to
have one piece of material that nobody
else laid a finger on so I wrote it I
directed it I acted in it I I edited it
I did the music I did the sound effects
I did the costumes I did the makeup I
casted who played the alien
shot that you saw that was Tom Green
under there there was about 15 different
people that played the alien my cousin
it was whoever I could get that weekend
so sometimes the alien's six feet tall
and sometimes sometimes it was my
girlfriend when she wasn't strapped to
the front of the car yeah I took her out
to the salt and seen him put her on a
sand dune and she was jumping around in
that thing in like 120 degree heat I'm
sorry all agents are still busy but it
was quite the I learned a lot I learned
everything I need to know about
filmmaking from doing that movie because
I had to do everything myself I feel
like that could be a cult classic yeah I
really think that that needs to be seen
by a lot more people yeah I really
should I wish it could yeah well it can
you just have to take the initiative and
give it to your agent yeah and go that
could be on an adult swim at night that
could be on Amazon or apple or people
can download Harlan Williams first
like it's like you're like scores when I
watch that I think I Scorsese yeah don't
you exactly yeah yeah it was amazing and
I and I thought that it was a creative
move to have the alien even in the
trailer being different sizes right I
thought that I would choose to watch
that before War of the Worlds if I was
gonna like really yeah stream something
I'm gonna watch the whole movie now I've
only seen the trailer and I can't wait
to go home and watch it so if I watched
it tonight it would be on YouTube
it might be on Amazon I did upload it on
there years ago but I don't know if it's
still there probably not if you check on
Amazon
fudgy wedgie Fudge Face yeah and is that
is it based on a true story no okay no
and how did you come up with the name it
just popped into my head you know one
night I it all started I bought those
fake buck teeth right and one night I
was at home bored and I put them in my
mouth and comb my hair like a greased up
hillbilly there's a poster oh yeah
there's the cover of the DVD is it on
Amazon
you know it's a great t-shirt you got to
make the fudgy wedgie Fudge Face T-shirt
oh it looks like it's awesome
video look you got four stars with six
reviews
let's read the reviews
there oh no I haven't even seen that
wait wait wait wait look at this the UFO
before you get to the reviews get to the
synopsis can you still download it or is
it still there I don't know
the first human the alien meets is a
hillbilly named Elmore P fudge the
dumbest man in the world okay that's
that's it let me see the reviews no
there's no written reviews but this
video is currently unavailable to watch
in your location oh so what location is
it available in I get this house I put
it on because the movie was so old I did
it so long ago I put it up there when
Amazon first started
and now I guess they took it down since
then when Beezus was selling books out
of his garage you can get this tape
but I want to put it back up somewhere
like no you need to no don't put it back
up I need you need to sell it you need
to have it on a legitimate streamer as a
a real piece of iconic the first movie
and I think it is really fun not just
YouTube Not Just upload it himself to
YouTube I think it'll get a lot of views
but I think that he I but I think he can
actually sell it I think people would
buy that you could buy the movie for
9.95 if you'd pay 3.99 delivery it'll
come between July 21st and August no
it's wall art
it's wall art what do you mean oh the
sign wall home art yeah metal tin design
they made it out of metal oh wow I
didn't even know that no well they did
it sold the last hard copy DVD about
five months ago you sold it I had boxes
of them in my garage yeah and then the
last one sold in my web store at
harlowwilliams.com so I had to put sold
out I got I got no more copies I love
just the title that's just a great
t-shirt fudgy wedgie Fudge Face yeah get
a fudgy wedgie Fudge Face t-shirt don't
you think those would sell guys back
there would you not buy one everybody's
got their thumbs up they're making a
great ice cream bar too oh you should
sell to Ben and Jerry's like if this
does well they should make a Ben and
Jerry's ice cream flavor wedgie Fudge
Face yeah with teeth in it you know it's
also funny like where it's selling or
where I don't know what what site we're
on right now Amazon we're on Amazon so
the next thing over is actually Valley
fudge chocolate pecan Turtles
yeah whatever it is you can buy fudgy
wedgie fudge fudge face or actually get
some real fudgy wedgie I love I don't
know whether I want fudgy fuzzy wedgie
fudge face or fudge
[Music]